[Musik]
die ausrüstung von soldaten
moderne waffensysteme
so wie kampf und gefechtsfahrzeuge
werden immer komplexer
[Musik]
die einführung und betreuung dieser
rüstungsgüter ist aufgabe des amts
gerüst und wehrtechnik das reicht von
der mitarbeit bei der erstellung des
pflichtenheftes der
leistungsbeschreibung bis zu knüpfen und
letztendlich abnahme des gerätes seit
150 jahren erbringt das amt seine
aufgaben am jeweiligen stand der technik
von der chemischen struktur des uniform
stoffes
über die ballistischen eigenschaften
verschiedenster munition
[Musik]
ein ziel zur analyse der schmier und
betriebsmittel des euro fiel
hier wird alles auf seine
funktionstüchtigkeit und belastbarkeit
geprüft
alles was hier gemacht wird der dienst
der sicherheit unserer soldaten in einem
stetig ansteigenden technologischen den
trend um die vielfältigen
herausforderungen bewältigen zu können
ist das awd in vier geschäftsbereiche
waffen und munition stech nick fahrzeuge
und pionier technik elektrotechnik und
optronik und die zentrale technische
produktdokumentation als militärischer
kernbereich des als kind die waffen und
munition stech nick hier werden
waffensysteme aller kaliber unter die
lupe genommen zu werden sturmgewehre
pistolen und maschinen war von extremen
belastungstest unterworfen
ob die anforderungen erfüllt werden
zeigt das anschließende funktions
schießen in europas längstem skis kanal
einen hohen stellenwert hat auch die
prüfung von werkstoffen explosivstoffen
sowie personen schutzausrüstung
[Musik]
der bereich fahrzeug und pionier technik
beschäftigt sich mit der einführung und
betreuung von fahrzeugen pionier geräts
und gerät der abc abwehr truppe und
stellt die aufklärungs fähigkeit
biologische gefahren des buches er
sicher auch prototypenbau zählt zu den
aufgaben
so wird die bremsanlage aller radpanzer
pandur mit eigens hier entwickelten
nahezu wartungsfreien keramik center
elementen ausgestattet
diese erhöhen die bremsleistung und
reduzieren die buddhistischen
aufwendungen
in der projektgruppe militär robotik und
automatisiertes fahren kann man bereits
einen blick in die zukunft werfen
von der taktischen robotischen
aufklärung und detektion von
kampfmitteln
bis hin zur vollautomatisierten
fahrzeugen ziehen dabei soldaten zu
unterstützen und zu schützen
[Musik]
elektrotechnik in unserer high tech
gesellschaft ist ein komplexes
unterfangen und reicht von energie über
sicherheits bis hin zur
medizingerätetechnik
jährlich werden mehr als 7000
elektromedizinische geräte durch das amt
in in und ausland geprüft
nach zählt wärmebild und lasertechnik
gehören die auch die klassische optronik
und die physikalische messtechnik dazu
der bereich umfasst österreichweit der
betreuung und instandsetzung von über 50
militärischen schießanlagen sowie die
einführung und betreuung der
erfolgreichsten jüngsten
schlüsseltechnologie der ausbildung
überhaupt der simulationstechnik das
österreichische bundesheer verfügt über
unzählige versorgungsgüter und jedes
einzelne davon und fälschung oder
granatwerfer muss ihn das logistische
informationssysteme eingebracht werden
hier werden konstruktionspläne
angefertigt etwa für adaptierungen
umbauten oder zur ausbildung an geräten
[Musik]
dritte aufgabe hier ist die
bereitstellung technischer vorschriften
für verwendete rüstungsgüter wie zb
waffen und fahrzeuge
[Musik]
der sich verstärkende technologiewandel
fordert die laufende bewältigung immer
neuer aufgabenfelder und
wissenschaftlichen disziplinen wie
jüngst bioinformatik und robotik diese
gilt es flexibel und zügig zu
integrieren und zu beherrschen
innovation und kreativität zitiert die
schlüsselelemente und prägen seit über
150 jahren die organisierte wehrtechnik
in österreich das amt für rüstung und
wehrtechnik folgt dieser tradition als
technisch naturwissenschaftliches
kompetenzzentrum des bundesministeriums
für landesverteidigung und des
bundesheers
[Musik]